What brought me specifically to Kitchens for Good
was actually looking for a job during the height
of the COVID pandemic.
And I really wanted to make sure I'm working
for an organization that I feel so passionately about.
And when I came across Kitchens for Good's job posting,
I knew that I had found the thing that I could do
and become even more passionate about.
I had a grandfather who was a cook.
He was a cook in the Navy.
And he ran hospital kitchens.
And he always spoke about giving people a chance
that might not otherwise have an opportunity.
And that kitchens were the perfect place
to get people started and to give them second chances.
So it just felt completely serendipitous.
And like, this is where I'm supposed to be,
even if it was kind of a crazy time in the world
and in my life as well.
Every day, you know, he was a big part of my life.
And I did spend a lot of time with him.
And so it wasn't something that I understood at that time
when I was with him.
It just kind of took up a space in the back of my brain.
And so to really be living that now,
I mean, I think about him every single day
that I'm doing this work.